dr jean claude tardif directeur du
centre de recherche de l'institut de
cardiologie de montréal professeur de
médecine adversaire montréal est avec
nous docteur tardif bonjour bonjour vous
êtes est le seul m'a pas le seul mais un
des seuls qui veut rentrer en contact
avec des gens qui ont la cote et 19
vous en avez besoin pour votre recherche
clinique rappelez-nous qu'est ce que
vous cherchez puis pourquoi vous en avez
besoin
alors chers civile 9 parce qu'on croit
qu'on est sur une bonne piste d'un
médicament qui pourrait prévenir les
complications la colle et isner c'est à
dire les hospitalisations le besoin de
ventilation mécanique avec un
respirateur
puis les décès c'est la fameuse
colchicine que vous allez tester qui est
un vieux vieux vieux médicaments qu'on
donnait contre la goutte qui ont des
problèmes articulaires 1,13 et très
sévère est-ce que déjà vous vous avez
l'intuition que ça va marcher vous avez
vu des ddd bon des bonnes réponses chez
des patients mais je présente au québec
des virologues des microbiologistes
toutes sortes de jeunes et oui on a
plusieurs évidences qui nous suggèrent
que ça pourrait fonctionner très
brièvement de dénominateur commun entre
l'épidémie grippe espagnole de la
pandémie actuelle des femmes ainsi que
les enfants sont infectés mais hanté de
complications est sans doute une des
raisons pour cela c'est que ils sont
capables de mettre les frais
demain sur la réaction inflammatoire et
on s'est probablement pourquoi
et l'autre chose vous savez on a appris
de ce qui s'est passé en chine et en
italie où on a vu des gens qui ont ce
qu'on appelle la tempête inflammatoires
et on sait bons centres pourquoi ils ont
ça est ce c'est ce genre de patients là
qui développe les comptes est assurée
porter donc la colchicine viendra dire
au corps humain de 2 - réagir leur
relaxe et il n'a pas besoin d'enfler les
poumons à ce point là pour ne pas être
obligé d'être un tube i par exemple
c'était ici c'est exactement ça on le
produit de la côte chine que vous aviez
dit ces jeux comme en 2001 les gens
avaient compris que ça fonctionnait
contre la côte quand vous avez été et on
vient de terminer ont publié nous il ya
deux mois un peu par hasard une étude de
5000 patients avec la colchicine dans un
autre contexte
après la crise cardiaque on a démontré
que ça excuse et les continuations et on
a de bonnes raisons pas assez que
bloquer la réaction inflammatoire
la robe est déjà souligné monsieur c'est
important que passent des fois il ya des
mauvaises informations / données là il
ya des jeunes et on dit tout à fait à
tort que la colchicine causer des
problèmes d'arythmie cardiaque c'est
absolument faux rythme cardiaque causée
par la colchicine non ça c'est la creule
la chloroquine menacé l'autre c'est
l'autre n'est pas exactement on a fait
leur devoir mais oui d'ailleurs mais
c'est normal que les gens soient mélange
de ces deux noms qui peuvent se
ressembler mais vous c'est monsieur
colchicine mais alors ma question
docteur c'est à quel moment vous allez
dire c'est tellement encourageant qu'on
pourrait peut-être même aller encore
plus vite qui en donnait aux gens dans
les hôpitaux qui ont de la misère à
respirer
très bonne question
on est je suis dans mes mots que réalise
l'urgence nous on est convaincu qu il
faut faire les choses dans les règles de
l'art pour répandre une question
importante pour les patients
les gouvernements et les systèmes de
santé puis prendre des décisions de
santé publique de qualité maintenant en
bêta pour bien faire l'étude mais faut
la faire rapidement
alors c'est pour ça qu'il faut recruter
les patients rapidement ont le nez plus
gros du québec est actuellement un
exemplaire monsieur le premier ministre
vous parler aujourd'hui je peux vous
dire que quand tout sur la planète
maintenant ça nous appellent pour
participent à l'étude et je crois qu'ils
ont pourtant accepté parce que ça va
nous permettre de recruter des patients
on veut compléter l'étude et ckoi très
rapidement pendant qu'on voit l'adresse
là c'est quoi très rapidement quand vous
dites très rapidement pour vous oui mais
notre souhait c'est de terminer de
recrutement toussenel on va faire une
annonce très importante demain et sur
quels sont les autres régions du globe
qui vont s'associer à nous et écouter
car événements et quand est-ce qu'on
peut terminer l'étude
il ya un comité de surveillance de
l'étude je serai pas les noms déjà parce
que je veux qu'ils puissent travailler à
tête reposée
mais il aime comme des cons vêtements et
dépendra de moi de mon équipe qui
surveille ça s'appelle le côté de
sécurité qui surveille les données et
dès qu'ils auraient une éducation qu'il
juge suffisamment crédible pour ses
études
les urgences et ça serait bon très bien
alors ça peut aller vite ça peut aller
vite jean-claude interdite on voit la
drees dr tardif à l'écran alors vous en
cherchez encore le ceux qui ont testé
positif si le temps d'écrire et en
donnant cette année cela n'a absolument
rien
oui puis si les gens appellent sets 7-5
3-6 6-3 7-5 à travers chaud il ya
soixante personnes 70 infirmières qui
seraient les 1 8 7 7 5 3 6 6 8 3 sets
parce que là les gens note à la maison
volé c'est assez longtemps à zoomer très
bien docteur merci on se reparle
merci monsieur roy